es un pescador de los antiguos julio
anselmo navega a diario las aguas del
lago de izabal cerca de la costa del mar
caribe de guatemala actualmente
contaminado por desechos tóxicos
en el 2017
era en el puro verano cuando se tiñó de
rojo casi la mitad del lago de izabal
con ello pescó que en el río arriba pero
ahí se miraba mira pero casi es como
sangre rojo julio representa al gremio
de pescadores de el estor el municipio
donde opera la compañía guatemalteca de
níquel subsidiaria de la minera suiza
soul de investment group que administra
la mina a cielo abierto a la que culpan
de la contaminación del lago ahora está
la mena
[Música]
antes sabía pescar pero ahorita casi
llano
sí
ahorita está duro la pesca ahorita así
como ahora te voy a levantar
no sé si captura algo el almuerzo pero
no hay
en el verano de 2017 los pescadores
comenzaron una batalla legal en contra
de la mina de níquel y el 19 de julio de
2020 la ganaron la corte de
constitucionalidad de guatemala ordenó
el cierre de la mina por operar bajo una
licencia que no respetó las cláusulas de
estudios de impacto ambiental pero la
compañía minera no acató el fallo y
prosiguió las extracciones en estas
montañas un perímetro de 250 kilómetros
cuadrados
este es el nacimiento de agua
vamos podemos ir a ver
voy a tomar el agua directamente bien
así sin miedo
ramón es un indígena maya de la etnia
kachin que habita el corredor montañoso
del lago de izabal su comunidad la de
agua caliente lucha abiertamente en
contra de la mina
porque si la compañía guatemalteca de
líquida va a escarbar quieres aquí
automáticamente el río se va a secar
verdad y la comunidad se va a quedar sin
agua este es el peligro
ramón sabe que la compañía guatemalteca
de níquel subsidiaria de la
multinacional suiza violó el acuerdo 169
de la organización internacional del
trabajo lo entendió gracias a las clases
de este hombre para
rodrigo tot uno de los líderes de agua
caliente que exige la necesidad de
consultarle a los pueblos indígenas si
una mina puede operar en sus tierras
ancestrales por eso levantamos la voz
porque la constitución
tiene que cumplirse
[Aplausos]
rodrigo representa a 64 familias
indígenas tradicionalmente patriarcales
las mujeres cocinan los alimentos que
cultivan los hombres en el denominado
lote 9 un territorio en pugna con la
mina
porque las mismas tierras que la abran
para la agricultura guardan en el
subsuelo grandes reservas de níquel
descubiertas tras una perforación en
aquí es donde hay en esta parte donde
está donde hay níquel por ejemplo ellos
ya ya saben que aquí hay buen material
entonces por eso quieren quitar esa
parte
y dejarnos nosotros con poquita tierra
aquí tenemos nuestra casa aquí están los
sembrados aquí están las mandarinas la
piña la yuca el cardamomo
como cuento falta
unos 20 minutos
ante la amenaza de ser desplazados de su
territorio rodrigo tot se convirtió en
el representante de su comunidad para
salvaguardar sus tierras ante los
tribunales en medio del proceso uno de
sus hijos fue asesinado pero todo no se
quedó callado y su lucha contra la mina
le valió ganar el golden innviron mental
price en 2017
en febrero de 2022 la corte
interamericana de derechos humanos
aceptó la demanda contra el estado de
guatemala en la defensa de los derechos
de los pueblos indígenas
pero mientras el alto tribunal
internacional estudia el caso en el
estor las opiniones sobre la mina están
divididas de los cerca de 3.000
empleados encontramos uno orgulloso de
sus cinco años como mecánico de
reparación
la mina fue positivo porque hay hay
trabajos estable más más empleados
directos y más comercios y más ingresos
beneficios para el pueblo de origen maya
que posee el freedom a kim pertenece al
mismo linaje de sus coterráneos que
batallan jurídicamente por custodiar los
títulos de propiedad de sus tierras
ancestrales
aquí nadie se le está quitando el
terreno que se calmen porque ellos se le
dieron las oportunidades ellos pudieron
trabajar pero
a los largos días ellos exportaron se
portaron mal con la empresa porque
siempre hablan mal porque porque ellos
mismos
ellos mismos se cierran las puertas
en el estor reina la incertidumbre por
quien va a ganar el pulso ante la
corteidh e h si los intereses económicos
de una gigantesca mina a cielo abierto o
los alegatos indígenas que tuvieron eco
en la pasada cumbre cop 26 de glasgow
donde concluyeron que estos pueblos
milenarios son los mejores protectores
del medio ambiente y por quienes se debe
apostar legalmente para frenar el cambio
climático